on se souvient tous de cet instant qui
nous a permis de croire ce jeu est
remplie d'histoires de héros légendaires
et comment ils sont nés là c'est une
autre histoire quand tu me regardes
dormi encore et de loin plus intéressant
que les cas bloqué dix minutes là c'est
quoi cette histoire j'ai tout mis ce que
j'avais dans ce tournoi tu as laissé
filer notre superstar chez un autre cote
qu'est ce que ce soit en dites moi ça
sent la rancune ça c'est l'occasion
idéale pour dax de rencontrer oncle
toulouse le plus grand basketteur de rue
que j'ai eue de toute ma vie
tiens mais noah tiens t'es noir chose
que tu veux c'est jouer comme jordan et
toi tu te prends pour qui
morgan freeman
à
les classements devant tout le monde
joue un mec comme toi pourrait fusionner
ancienne école est nouvelle et crestron
mon équipe et mes athlètes ce quoi
gameboy livres électroniques
allez on va chercher les copains tour
mais l'équipe son pied dégâts faits
datent monde à aller jeter un oeil sur
le ballon kobe ou tu m'as dit que ces
cas là ce avait joué celui là c'est au
karatéka effets de la méditation
le gars qui aime aller voir du tout aidé
à son équipe de grand père alors tu as
donné à chacun de tes vieux un bracelet
medicalert je sens encore des doutes
une surprise pour chaque anneau
pour le basket c'est bon c'est trop bon
j'ai maintenant
on y va
tu joues comme il faut tout s'arrange
l'un des gages c'est le moment de vérité
alors tu dégonfle où tu t'accroches et
tu fonces
moi je veux des paniers
[Applaudissements]
oh
moi je veux m'assurer que ce gars là est
assez grand pour se mesurer à mon mec
qui s'apprête à l'humiliante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]